4 22 starts against miami the opponent's
hitting no 91 against the scherzer
slider
say that fast five times 13 and fourth
of 308 and 22 career starts against the
marlins play ball underway right on time
405 and that one is 4-3 from josh
harrison to save pitching staffs and to
make up games lost to the coronavirus
big breaking ball sure zero strikeout
that's his 40th of the year
oh that's off for scherzer
redirects to harrison a 1-4-3
paul lessard's going to come and greet
max scherzer on his way back to the
dugout so for dan castano third major
league starts juan soto stands in the
way that they're constructed because of
the way the roster is and guys in and
out no soto great change up
look it's soto a no contact first inning
but a threat
nonetheless
swinging a ground ball toward the hole
it's off the glove of rojas turner is
scored from third but kendrick holding
up at second with a ball hit on the
ground in front of him and on at first
as his drubal cabrera he'll pick up an
rbi and probably a base hit as well
either way the nationals are on the
board first here in the bottom of the
first inning it's washington one in
miami nothing and the nats have
something big brewing early
payoff pitch coming
and suzuki pops one up left field that's
gonna be dickerson to put it away
kendrick retreats and there are two outs
so one of those two things happened for
a manager to go into his bullpen like
that ah two out base hit for harrison
here comes howie
throw cut off he crosses home plate
before the tag so it's two nothing nets
swing a tip and a strikeout
number two for scherzer we were talking
jp and i were talking before the game
today aaron sebia about the job that
cervelli
you see kibum went around on that
breaking ball so first strikeout for
josh
they will be going to new york
at the moment that's still the plan
and maybe we'll have a double header
this is sanchez in the corner
and he made the catch disappearing into
the right field corner
able to make the play
did stand up
rojas went fishing and he's out
first time around the order the fish
with a dickerson single go one for nine
and that strikeout number three
tie runs are aboard in the marlins third
inning
with jesus aguilar facing scherzer
payoff pitch
is hit down the left field line aguilar
hoping for it this one is
[Applause]
and out toward the concourse aguilar
kind of knew it though he hunched down
was leaning hoping it would stay fair
he'll do it again and that's also
hammered deep down the left field line
with foul like the pitch before it was
up and in and out of the strike zone
and he's out of the inning with 97.
aguilar slamming his bat in his helmet
and now the marlins compelled to bring
their infield in with that runner at
third and that's leading two nothing in
the third howie gets jammed and hits it
well to center
it's going to back up sierra easily
scoring trey turner
so trey picks up soto and then howie
picks up the rbi and then that's lead
swang and gonna miss on 95
and that's number five
that's a little power fastball here a
little cut to it maybe at the end not by
design
[Applause]
i mean he's been 95-97 all day
and brings in josh harrison who had an
rbi single
oh another q shot to the right side
suzuki heading for third
he's in there ball gets away he's coming
home
harrison heading for third it's a little
league triple
and the nats lead four nothing and the
nats have a corner situation with nobody
out victor robles
roble's got a breaking ball lines it
right at the left fielder and it's
dropped by dickerson
might have been knuckling on him it was
hit so hard balls on the ground and the
nets lead five to nothing but that
should be sacrificed
now it's just a matter of execution goes
out there trusts his speed trusts his
legs trust his defense and his legs are
going to be on display right here as
he'll round third and score on a base
hit from jonathan vr the marlins crack
the scoreboard here in the fifth and
trail it five to one here's matt joyce
who has a strikeout and a walking strike
to joyce and matt joyce with a fly ball
right center field going back this one's
gonna carry out of here
a two-run home run for matt joyce
marlin's creep back into the game
and it's five to three
all right well the big moment has found
jesus sanchez max
the tail end of his start has given up
three runs in the inning
3-0
[Applause]
and ball four inside off the plate
sanchez gets his first rbi on a bases
loaded walk and the marlins are within a
run
five nothing earlier this inning now
it's five to four so kyle finnegan
inherits a bases loaded situation
right in there
inning over
chopper up the middle backhanded and the
flip to rojas what a pretty double play
vr to miggy to aguilar and they get the
twin killing
oh
the beautiful turn by the boys in the
middle
swing and a miss
nets win it
daniel hudson comes out throwing bbs
that the marlins can't do much with